um thinking about my own past
experiences
are british nationals too lazy to fill
the gaps left by european workers well
that's a bit of a zinger um before i put
into a panel when you say thinking about
your own experiences what what what do
you mean
um i'm thinking about a bit back when
i've done summer jobs picking fruit and
i'll admit that i was probably one of
the lazy british workers while all the
eastern european workers in particular
worked
so so much harder than myself and my
british colleagues so that's yeah that's
what i'm talking about my specific
example
well
louise brown asks are british nationals
too lazy to fill the gaps left by
european workers before i come to our
studio panel i want to come to come back
to the wall um
louise's question british workers too
lazy to fill the gaps left by european
workers
who agrees
with that
statement can i see those who agree with
that statement i see your hands
and i'm looking
and just wave them so we can see them
clearly uh yeah we're seeing somewhere
between maybe 30 40 percent okay you can
put your hands down who disagrees with
the idea that british workers are too
lazy to fill those jobs
uh left by european workers
well
it's interesting probably around the
same number maybe it's uh maybe about 40
50 percent okay let me come back into
the studio i'll remember it
um
lewis brown basically doesn't think that
we've got a real immigration problem
what we've got is a laziness problem
um i think there's a lot of people that
would be offended at that but that aside
are our workers lazy absolutely not but
if you're getting someone from a poor
country who's used to working
frankly the all the hours that god sends
to uh to work and break their backs
and you have someone from here who's got
commitments who's got payments to make
people from poor countries got
commitments too you know no they haven't
got them to the extent that those who
are they've got families they've got
houses
i'm sorry but someone who is say
living working on a little farm in
romania where i've i've
lived and worked is not going to have
the same commitments or needs to someone
all right living in a city in this
country
theo um
let's not mess we use the word lazy but
maybe british workers aren't as
keen
uh and as committed to some kind of work
as people from abroad
i don't think that's right i think
you'll never match
employment with vacancies fully you
never have 100
full employment and no unemployment
whatever we do we're always going to
have a percentage of unemployment and at
the moment
quite rightly as we just heard we're
looking to fill not just
average paid jobs but highly skilled
paid jobs we're talking about six figure
salaries there is still a shortage of
people and so we need to make sure that
we attract the right people to run our
country and our economy and the right
legislation led by government because
there's no point saying it's up to
business if government puts in
legislation all right that stops you
doing something
business can't do anything about it